[Music]
hi everyone welcome to today's lecture
again we are going to
see attacking games and it will start
with a game that everybody should know
a game between played between rock lewie
and rubinstein
it's been called the immortal game
actually it's been called rubinstein's
immortal game because
that's a fabulous uh
game with a series of sacrifices and
combinations
so let's have a look it started in a
quiet way actually in a
very
symmetrical position
so here we have a totally symmetrical
position
here white probably made the first
questionable decision to take on c5
right away um usually you riser wait for
black to develop the f8 bishop and then
you take on c5
so that black loses his tempo first play
playing bishop e7 for example and then
take on c5
however of course if you do not take on
c5 you give an extra option to play c
takes d4 that's probably what white
wanted to avoid so he played d takes c5
and now a3 wants to push b4 so far this
is very reasonable for white
black played a6
b4 bishop d6
so a6 will prove useful
i don't think knight b5 would be a real
strat but a6 is anyway useful because at
some point black would like to take on
c4 and play b5
just like what did why did so bishop b2
was played castle
and here white played a very weird move
he played queen d2
in that sort of position you never put
the queen there
it would have been more normal to
i think the most natural way to play
would have been to take
may force black uh an isolated pawn and
then play bishop e2 short castle with a
very normal position
and anything would have been better than
queen d2 i mean also bishop d3 it's true
that
then black can take on c4 and compared
to
white black has won a tempo because he
has waited for white to develop the
bishop
so that's why i think
this was definitely the most natural way
to play
but queen d2 was really weird
so of course i did not mention but
the pawn is
not possible to take because of knight
takes and bishop b4
and then queen takes d5 and the queen is
lost so the queen is lost here
but queen d2 is a really strong square
for the queen
i mean the only idea i could see
behind this this move would be to play
long castle but long castle when you
have your pawns on b4 and c4
that cannot be serious and
white actually didn't do it in the game
um
black played queen e7 he wants to go
rogue d8 and take advantage of the miss
of the queen on d2 which will have to
move again
now it would be possible for
white to take the pawn but even there so
now bishop before check would not win
the queen but there black would have a
very
hugely
a very serious deal in development
um and definitely great compensation for
the pawn
here white played bishop d3
black took on c4
played b5
rock d8 now bla white is having problems
on the d file so we move this queen to
e2
bishop b7 short castle and now have a
look at the position
we have a completely symmetrical
position except that black already has
his rock on the eight
and it is also black to move
which is
which means that white really rant wrong
because normally if the position is
symmetrical white should have an extra
tempo
and there is two tempi down so
white definitely went wrong but still
the position looks very solid and black
should take should make a good decision
here
as if you allow some trades let's say
with 94 and so on why it will probably
manage to equalize anyway
black played 95 which is a very good
move
because the knight on c6 was anyway
um blocking the diagonal of the bishop
and the knight on f3 is a very important
piece to develop
to to
to defend the white king after the
actions on e5 you can see that there are
there there is no piece
on any of these three
um
columns and there is no piece in front
of the white king
so black here already have threats like
queen d6 or queen c7
attacking here or there and attacking on
h2 attacking h2 as well
or first bishop takes h2
and then
a check on d6 or
a check on d6 and take the bishop on d3
so to avoid this white played f4
now where would you retract your bishop
c7
exactly so bishop c7 is a very good move
because on white is gonna play e4 on the
next move i mean f4 if you don't play f4
next
does not make any sense
so e4 has to be played and the bishop
would be doing excellent on b6 then the
bishop on b2 will be extremely misplaced
it would be much better on e3
here black could have given a check but
he first played draw kc8
white push if pushed e5
so he's opening the diagonal of the
light squared bishop but on the other
hand he's closing the diagonal of the
dark squared bishop
black gave a check
king h1 and now already if you have a
look at the position
the two rooks
are the two open files
the bishops are on the two
best possible diagonals
it's difficult to dream of a better
setup for black so black is definitely
doing very well here but he has one
night move that is particularly strong
here can you find it
knight g4
yes knight g4 is a very strong move
going in the direction of
the white king black is already
straightening
queen h4 and if h3 then queen takes h3
mate
is also threatening knight takes h2
followed by queen h4 he is also
threatening to enter with a knight
if white takes a bishop then after rock
d3 that's quite a disaster this is
hanging and rock d2 is also a strat
attacking the bishop and the pawn on g2
this is just dead last for white
taking on h7 first takes a pawn but it
actually only makes things worse because
the rock immediately comes to d2
why does
what white took opponents on h7 and so
what
the rock is already on d2 the game is
just over
if white tries to go knight e4 for
example to
cut the diagonal
well first of all knight xh2 would
probably be reasonable but best
should probably be rocktek's d3
with this typical idea queen h4
queen g3
forcing white to take to avoid checkmate
on h2 and queen h4 mate
so why decided to play bishop e4
now
that would be
a very easy win for black now it takes
h2
so the knight is a cannot be talking
because of queen h4 mate and if bishop
b7 of course not queen b7 because then
white would
take the knight on h2 but first knight
takes f1 streetening mate on h4 it's
retaining a fork on g3
in the at the very worst next you take
back on b7 and you have an extra
exchange and an extra pawn
so that's completely game over but
rubinstein apparently that day really
wanted to
get a brilliant prize
and he played queen h4
so here white play g3 to defend h2 with
a queen
h3 was the alternative
and then how could black continue
a bit similarly to lines we have seen
just just a minute ago
not queen g3 because now i can take with
the queen on g4
bishop c3
queen h3
um
there is a bishop on e4
so in the chat
i manny tried to go even further the
line the line continues queen takes g4
in the line you're giving
try to go even further
so knight f2 will not be a bad move but
king h2
i don't really see a force 2 in there
so rock takes c3
queen takes g4
for example
or
actually no rock takes c3 i'll let me
play bishop takes c3
takes g4
now that actually works
takes
takes
bishop takes e4
now this is obviously a checkmate with
the same ideas we've seen before
and if queen takes g4
takes takes
now we have this very important move
rock d3
and we have a double strat which is to
take the bishop and to check mate
on h3
so this wins for black
we will have two very strong bishops for
a rock
after
rock takes history if bishop b7 then
this is an immediate mate
and if queen takes g4
then this is very strong
takes steaks steaks
check
rock d2 collecting the bishop on the
actually not you don't even have to
collect the bishop you can
checkmate your opponent
so h3 loses to rock takes history
so in the game we decided to go g3 and
now how to continue with black what was
rubinstein's idea and just in this
position
because you may wonder what he is doing
now the queen is hanging h2 is protected
the bishop on b7 is hanging
of course you can always trade on e4 but
that's not really what you want
so what was rubinstein's id in this
position
here started the really
incredibly brilliant part of the game
rock d2
i can take it
then bishop takes b7
okay you gave many pieces so bishop
takes c8
i've collected many pieces with white
and so far you have only connected one
pawn
you know
pick up
bishop's still on b2
right
yeah but you only
i mean takes takes takes i take so white
as an extra piece if you go rogue d2 now
it's a piece and a rock you get a piece
back but you're still a rock down here
not so you have a little bit of counter
play but the rock is
a little bit too much
i mean unless you have something
concrete of course actually
it's almost it could almost work uh
well i mean
actually i'm wondering
that might work actually in ig4 and i
don't see how to prevent
rock h2 mate
so maybe i shouldn't take on c8 maybe i
should play something else
but i don't know what
so that might work as well
well i'm curious to check it
now apparently it doesn't dis loses
i was right on this but here for example
knight e4
to
get rid of the rock and
now if knight g4 there will be knight c5
always
and the king can escape to g1
so this is not working
so here
black plays rock takes history
sacrificing his queen
white has to accept the gift i mean to
take the queen if you just capture the
rook this is easy bishop takes and then
there'll be checkmate on h2
this is not really a move either because
now black has an extra pawn and a
winning attack
so
here there is no need for concrete
calculation because black has the attack
and an extra pound
so critical is to take the queen and now
how does black continue
rook to e3 i would just take on e3 and
then take on b7 and again i would uh
stay with extra material
but you're right that you need the key
is to eliminate this bishop on e4
but it should not cost you your
lightweight bishop
because you you're going to
you want to kill white on this diagonal
and rock is three you allow queen takes
e3 bishop takes b7 and
the attack is over
so here the crashing move with the same
idea as rocky 3
is rock d2
now if white for example takes here this
is just over now
black can take everything
bishop takes f3 this might even be this
might be even stronger with forced
checkmate
um
this is just over
um straightening bishop takes e4 but
also streaming rock takes h2 mate
um
this is also is the same threatening uh
bishop threatening rock takes b2 but
also rock takes h2 mate so quintex d2
has to be played
of course bishop takes e4
queen g2 and now the final blow
exactly because if you
rock h3 because if you take on g2 and
give a check
then okay king g3 attacking the knight
and the position is unclear
but rock h3 and it's a fourth checkmate
on h2
white can even play rook f3 bishop f3
and next okay next is rocktakes h2
checkmate
so
this way ended
the game and look at the black pieces
well first of all look at the material
balance
how many pieces were black sacrificed
but
all of the black pieces are playing a
crucial role in the attack
all of the black pieces are on the
perfect square so that
the the combination works
so that's this game is really a must now
that's uh one of the most famous
attacking games of all time so
that that was rottley we ravenstein
played in 1907.
so now let's see another game
played between topalov and kasparov in
1996
so the game was a nightdorf
typical kasparov
and topolov went for the southern
variation bishop c4 which was still
popular at the time nowadays
it is not being played very often
e6 bishop b3
knight d7 this is one of the main lines
black wants knight c5 and wants to take
the bishop
f4
knight c5
here queen f3 is a possible move and the
alternative is short castle
sacrificing the pawn e4 of course black
does not have to take it
but if he doesn't take it then white is
happy that he hasn't wasted a tempo
playing queen f3
so in the game kasparov took the pawn
which is actually probably the best move
objectively
takes takes f5
now black cannot afford opening the
position his king is in the center he
needs to close it with e5
queen h5
their kasparov played queen e7 which was
supposed to be the right move at the
time then chess engines showed that d5
is probably a little
safer um then the sir then siri
continues
rookie one
bishop c5 because if takes then rock
takes e4
you cannot take the rock because of
queen f7 mate and this is problematic
for black
but bishop c5
rock takes c4
and now two choices one is to take on d4
and for example
here white can sacrifice and it has a
bishop berry has nice compensation but
black pays f6
the white has compensation but probably
not not for an advantage
actually topple off lost the game in
this position later
and an alternative after rock takes c4
is to castle
as in case of rock take c5 their bb shop
takes d4 check
then row g4
king h1 e4
white has some attack black has an extra
pawn the position is a complete mess
but this is probably the safest for
black d5 i mean if you know your opening
if you know what to do then d5 is just
okay for black
but at the time of course
just engines will not
were not telling you immediately what
the right move is so kasparov played
queen e7
topolof went back to f3
ed4
rocky one the game is basically over
then rock takes e4 and we set a king in
the center
black's position is a disaster
so kasparov played knight c5
and he wants to eliminate this
bishop uh this bishop b3 which is always
um
the most important piece for white in
the southern i mean there is a reason
why you play bishop c4 bishop b3 you
want the bishop on the diagonal and
especially now that f5 has been played
and black has played e5 the diagonal is
completely open
so black is dreaming of eliminating his
bishop
here topalov found a way
to keep the bishop alive
so how did he manage this because the
knight on d4 is
hanging and knight takes b3 is being
straightened
so what did topple of play here
essence
f6
would not do much i could
i would just take with the bone
so knight c6 and if kings and if queen
c7
exactly
couple of went knight c6 so
if pontext and queen takes and the rock
on 8 is lost
kasparov moved his queen and now
toppolov played bishop d5
it could be tempting to go knight b4 to
put the knight on d5
but that would just
without the bishop
white would have no attack first of all
queen takes b3 would be forced otherwise
queen b6 jack is going to win the b for
knight
and now for example b5
then b and then queen c6 bishop b7
and white
probably has some compensation because a
knight on d5 is nice but is definitely
not better
so bishop d5 that's the key move
kasparov played a5 he wants to trap the
knight
on c6
for example if bishop d7 now knight b4
and black has a very pleasant position
if bishop is 7 for example then queen h5
if castles then
rock f3 and white already has a winning
attack
for example queen c8 trying to be smart
so that after rock h3 black can take the
pawn on f5
here bishop h6 would be a fantastic
attacking move
and just bring the rock to f1 protect f5
and the rock is gonna come to age free
that's gonna be
a check made very soon
so actually
rook f8 would be the only move here and
obviously white would have fantastic
compensation
if instead of bishop e7 black tries to
be smart with queen b6
attacking the knight and threatening a
discovery check
under the long diagonal
there bishop f7 would win the game
takes knight d5
the queen goes somewhere
check
the king has to go to g8 f6 then f7 and
the game is over
so bishop d7 is quite dubious a5 is
probably is best and is also quite human
i mean the knight is a bit weird on c6
you want to trap it
here topolov played bishop g5
simply
making an extra square available for is
knight
and now kasparov plundered he played
rock a6
bishop d7 would have been critical
so after bishop d7 what do you think
white should play
so bishop takes f7 is very tempting and
he's been played by a french grand
master
jean-marc de grav
he took an f7
but actually after king takes queen h5
and f6 just like we've seen before
after bishop e8 he had to resign
because black is controlling the f7
square enough times
and black is losing and white has lost a
lot of material and he's also going to
lose his c6 knight
so bishop f7 might have been what
kasparov was afraid of but it is not
working
critical here would be knight e7
and after 97 there is on only one way
for black not to lose the game white is
now threatening to take on f7 obviously
and play queen h5 and the king cannot
even escape to g8
black needs to take
if he plays f6
then queen h5
king takes
bishop f6 it's a smart move order
because if you start like this then
black can go king c8
so you start bishop f6 obviously king
takes the king is gonna get mated queen
f7 should also be a mate but this is
even quicker
i mean mate is coming very soon
pawn takes then queen f7
and you're taking the rock
you push your f pawn and
white white and white is simply
white is simply winning here
so bishop e7 would be critical and now
bishop e7
and if you take my bishop
i will play f6
and i'm going to demolish you
so you can't touch the bishop
white wants to play f6 and keep a very
strong bishop
on
e7
so it is quite tempting for black to
play f6 here
trapping the bishop preventing white
from playing f6
but queen g4 seems pretty strong
as there is no way to defend the g7 pawn
and now black on
would only have one move to save the
game can you find it
g6
so g6
wouldn't be good
i would play well first of all i could
also have gone queen g3 then there would
be no
pin of the f pawn but g6
i could take on f6 or even stronger
might be
to take
queen h4 for example
and if you take the bishop then take
sweetening to take on f7 if you put a
rock on f8 then i push g7
and you're just lost
bishop f5 ergo queen takes g7
then i take your rock
and i have a big material advantage
so here the only move for black to
survive is bishop e6
the idea being being that if you take on
g7 black is able to go rogue g8
and then black wins
because it's gonna take on d5 next
so okay you can take on e6 queen e7
it has compensation
but black is very solid here
this is a this is just unclear
why doesn't rock ga work
first
because my bishop on d5 is controlling
g8
so
queen g4 and this is the only move
and then black is more or less okay
that would have been the critical line
after bishop d7
but instead kasparov played rock a6
and he just allowed toparav to play
knight g8
and then knight f7
attacking the rock
and although we've seen plenty of
sacrifices
actually white is only a pound down here
because black rejected all sacrifices
so rock g8
now topalov simply played bishop e3
black is completely paralyzed
kasparov played g6
knight g5 and what is very impressive i
like to call this game the knight dance
because look at the manoeuvre that the
knight has done
the g1 knight is now on g5 so you would
expect it to go to f3 and then to g5
with it actually it has actually gone
through d4 c6 d8 f7 and then g5
all this in just 20 moves
so that's not something you see every
day
so white just wants to capture the rock
on g8
black played rock g7 that would be
actually bishop there you would not even
take on g8 this would be even stronger
with the idea that if the rock moves you
check
and then
queen f6 or even bishop g5
if bishop b7 then f8
and
it's game over
so in the game black played rock g7
takes
bishop f7
black sacrificed this queen
they played this position where black on
he has two bishops of the queen so it
took double up some time to win the game
like another 25 moves or something
actually more took him another 40 moves
so casper three gave it all to try to
hold this position but obviously white
has an extra queen
and in the end he won the game
so that is
that was total of kasparov
i think one of his
i mean one one of couple of brilliancies
especially with this man this night man
over which which i love the knight going
through the a to g5
okay let's see a third game
so white uh
was le grand valley
and with black
was playing peter axe
so vanville was a stronger player
with a rating close to 2700 and black's
rating was close to 2600
i used the word demolish a little bit
earlier in this
in this lecture and i see that in the
chat
people liked it very much
because they are using it
all the time okay so the opening was the
names of indian pretty normal opening
knight bishop d3
[Music]
y2k 92 that's a standard setup
rocky 8
castle the bishop came back to d6
we have a normal position
but white should always be careful if
the knight is on f3 his king is very
safe
with the knight on e2 white has to be
careful i mean he always has to watch
out for bishop takes h2
this kind of thing
but he played white played a3 very
calmly because after bishop h2
knight g4
of course not king g1 because that would
be a disaster white would have to go
rocky one
and
after quid takes f2
not just black would have at least a
perpetual check with queen h4 but most
likely
the raw could join the attack and that
should be
that should be winning for black
but bishop h2 the white thing would go
to g3 and without dallas with bishop
it would be very difficult to check mate
for example h5 f4 and the white king is
going to hide on f3
and the this is not working for black
simply
so van very was not afraid of bishop h2
he decided to play a3
he could have played i mean he could
have played h3 just avoiding any tactics
but okay he calculated that bishop h2
was not a problem so he played a3
preparing to play b4 and
play a positional game on the queen side
but their black played knight g4
after what
the most natural move is h3
probably objectively speaking g3 would
have been better but it's
making many holes on the light squares
that's positionally very ugly
so h3 is pretty logical
and now how do you think peter x
continued
so queen h4 i could have played but it's
not threatening very much probably just
knight xd5
and it
but queen h4 is a possibility
instead black found something stronger
so knight h2 rocky one
knight
f3
context f3
g5
queen g5
king h1
if i play knight d okay king f1 is
bishop takes h3 checkmate
this is not very good either
for example that is a checkmate
so king h1
and now black played queen h4
there's quite a few strats f2 is hanging
h3 is hanging
obviously the biggest threat is to take
on h3
so white played knight f4 which is
pretty much the only move if knight g1
just bishop takes h3
and there is no way white can defend
this of course if he takes you do not
give a check with the queen you first
check with the bishop and you have this
typical idea of
checkmate
on f2
white plays a random move let's say he
takes the pawn on d5 he's very greedy he
wants to take a pawn then takes and
again we have the same idea
so black needs white needs to plug the
diagonal of the d6 bishop
that's why i played knight f4
black played
bishop takes h3
this is not a move because of queen g5
check then next you take on f4 and you
threaten queen g2 mate
so
white played knight cd5 which is very
risky but
it is not so easy for black to find the
best
the best continuation
so now how did black
play
you have to bring another piece to the
attack
exactly rookie six very good
if the rook reaches h6 then it's game
over so white has to take it
and now black has a fantastic way to win
the game
there is one land which is actually even
more fantastic but unfortunately does
not win the game
there is only one concrete wind here
and this is probably one of the last
moves you would think of
at first at least
so did somebody find the chat no not yet
bishop g3
we showed g3 and if i take it
no not bishop j3
so
bishop g4 is tempting
because you can win the queen
but white has many pieces for the queen
here for example knight takes on c7 or
even just knight f4
and white has many pieces for the queen
this position is actually very unclear
if you count if you count the pieces
even just even after a simple knight f4
attacking the queen the queen has to go
then the bishop is lost
um if you count the pieces
white has
two pieces and a rock for the queen
of course black can take on f2 he has
some pawns some initiative
but this is not so clear
another thing which is not so clear is
bishop takes e6 i would like to hide
this from
i mean this is also possible black
black is an uh i mean white has an extra
exchange but obviously black has
compensation
but this is also not so clear
this is a mistake because white will
just play i mean black is returning mate
on g2 and on h2 but by playing knight f4
white
prevents everything
and
the black attack just fall just fails
a very nice line which
usually my students
propose
when i give them this position is bishop
f1
and a very cute move bishop e2 because
if you take my bishop with whatever
piece
i will go queen h2 and queen h1 mate
this is extremely cute
but unfortunately again just knight f4
and takes takes quite as many pieces for
the queen and this is also not so clear
so it doesn't leave
that many options
what else what could be the win for
black
yes i see bishop f1 bishop it was now
been proposed in the chat but it is
well it's definitely it would be much
better if bishop f1 bishop b2 would work
because
that would be really really beautiful
but
it is not a concrete win
here black has a forced checkmate
quintex f2 as i said just knight f4
prevents everything
so ariana in the chat can you give me
the full continuation not just the first
move
okay so here the win is bishop f5 check
which is
i see at least
let's say in a blitz game that would be
the last move i would think of i would
consider bishop g4
i would consider taking on e6 and taking
on d5
if i if i if if i if i saw this bishop
f1 bishop e2 i would also consider and
most likely play it because it looks so
nice but bishop f5 is not the first move
you think of
because it doesn't look like it's doing
much
but actually after king g1
queen h2
king f1 now black has a killer which is
bishop to g3
and the bishop on f5
turns out to be the decisive piece
because if white wants to prevent a
checkmate on f2
okay of course pawn takes g3 is bishop
h3 mate
and if white plays any move to prevent
a checkmate on f2 then
black will take on d3 the black queen we
have to take and
a checkmate will follow
so here there is no difference after
bishop g3
what that is white had to resign
in just
18 moves
so not every day a player rated 2700
loses with white
in just 18 moves
okay so
here we are for today
do you have any questions
okay then i will see you
i think tomorrow same time if i'm not
wrong
why
thursday thursday for sure uh wednesday
i'm not sure
there's nothing going on with the gm
tomorrow
okay so i will see you on thursday same
time
thanks for watching thanks for your
comments
and uh well see you in two days
[Music]
it's time for the return of the grand
chess tour featuring the world's best
players in some of the most unique
places across the globe romania poland
croatia and the united states join us in
may as we kick off the 2022 tour in
romania and then immediately followed by
poland this is your chance to see the
best players in the world's greatest
game follow all of the action live at
grandchesttour.org
chess the smartest game on earth